hello I am Phil and I directed this
episode of odd man out
alright I'm Evan and I did not direct
this episode of odd man out this video
is brought to you by manscaped calm the
first company to sponsor us that relates
directly to our private parts
introducing the perfect package 3.0 kit
which includes everything you need to
take your grooming routine to the next
level this is the new lawnmower 3.0
waterproof body trimmer for a limited
time subscribers get not one but two
free gifts the shed travel bag which is
a travel bag and the patented high
performance anti chafing manscaped
boxer-briefs
get 20% off plus free shipping on your
perfect package 3.0 purchase when you
use promo code jube
that's Jub 20 at man escapes comm stick
around after the episode to learn more
and now let handgrip into hand and i
look i - i brakes wait we brought
together six people who are in a
fraternity I am in a fraternity and I'm
in a fraternity I'm in a fraternity
I'm gonna fraternity I'm in a fraternity
I made a fraternity one of them is a
liar or maybe more than one actually
sorry I said too much
if the group discovers who the liar is
they'll split a cash prize
if the liar survives they win the entire
prize this is odd man out
there's a catch and the game operates
exactly the same if there are multiple
moles still left in the game they're all
right either it's a trick and there's
just one mole or there could be maximum
two or three yeah when you when you say
multiple moles were at play through my
strategy out the window
my name is Abe I'm affiliated with Beta
Theta Pi Beta Chapter that I graduated
from Chapman University in 2017
I'm Tyree I'm from Phi Mu Alpha and Beta
Chapter Henry Alpha Delta Phi
adolfo chapter I'm Evan Kappa Alpha
order and then Delta Gamma chapter I'm
Julian I'm signify out of UC Berkeley
Alpha Gamma chapter I'm Isaiah out of
tile Kappa Epsilon
Beta Sigma at University of Southern
California everybody go around and say
how many people they have in their PC
let's PC pledge class oh the first
person to admit that they don't know
something is immediately suspected yeah
that was that was a big red flag I
didn't know what a PC was either so it's
pledge class like I don't know PC seems
really formal um you want to go over
like just a basic stat of basic
information of your frat I guess I'll
start my colors is a blue and pink
colors are red gold and black are you
rockin anything I mean gold black
green gold maroon and black
ours are crimson red and then gold
alright ours are Yellin red comes in the
bed and gray oh I got nothing there like
some people that who for sure struggled
with answering the questions
his story definitely seen 50 he didn't
seem very confident he very much looked
like a frat guy he didn't look like he
was in a frat to me to be honest I'm
sheen assumed that it's because I didn't
know what the PC was I thought he was in
a fraternity with his clothing it was
more of like a mix-up because usually
like it's the standard like snapback
stuff like that the thing that sucks
about this is like we can only say so
much I know and there's only like so
much so that's such a good like oh it's
a secret you know like what are you
gonna say about that we're on camera we
can't tell our secrets I'm trying to
think of like public stuff so like what
year was your fraternity established oh
the the Alpha are you telling my alpha
colony the very first one uh yeah the
very first one August 8th of 1839 it was
by 8 founders just saying like notable
like the CEO of Walmart mine is Zac
Brown do you guys never like Zac Brown
Band all those I know I figured people
would know his background I don't know
I'm not even a country fan we should
have like some general questions right
like okay so one would be like what's
your frat sak affiliation to your school
sororities yeah okay yeah that's that's
a yeah it's ZTA
for us okay we have tri delt so we have
Delta Gamma and Kappa Kappa Kappa Gamma
oh those are my sister Delta Pi
oh I said what was it Kappa Kappa Gamma
and Delta Gamma that's those two are my
sororities as well interesting
I bought a prize via because I was so
confident that Evan was in a fraternity
[Music]
Isaiah was just kind of quiet the whole
time he didn't really say much and then
when he agreed with a bond them both
having the same sorority
I believed able a lot more than I
believed Isaiah I thought okay
they wouldn't throw someone who like
checks all the boxes of a frat guy in in
the stage I'm just trying to play the
game in my head not the guy like myself
I didn't mean to vote for Evan I
actually meant to vote for Abraham so
when Evan walked off I was like oh man I
think I messed it up so I have a
question can you guys name Q guys's
philanthropies your most recent one or
ones prior sure uh to develop men of
principle for a principle life and you
want my core values
no no philanthropy like events for those
who don't know philanthropy is an event
that you throw as a fundraiser like
charity and stuff like that so I went
too long I've done stuff that long beach
at the VA hospital um so we're a a
musical fraternity so like chamber choir
composition stuff like that so usually
when we do philanthropies it's to like
host like musical events and stuff like
that it sounded a little odd that he was
in a musical fret because I've never
heard that in my life are as we do a
yearly Twitter I've that's kind of like
our main thing ours is gonna be in the
spring most of the fall ones they were
sorority so we didn't have the chance to
like have ours but do you guys have a
handshake that you show in public
so for instance for me up you know we're
betas so we did a slap pound and then we
make a B symbol and then we slap our
chests
so as we're passing by each other going
to class just like that for me it's just
so like same thing walking around see
your brother left so you don't actually
show it like that's kind of like you
don't have a public one yeah it's like
the same we don't have cuz like the
whole I guess a point of it I believe
you here I got one for what those guys
that were like it gets involved you
probably know the songs do you guys want
to just like sure sure just like a short
part like we don't have to go through
the whole thing or anything pull out
nervous now Oh nervous in the whole not
like that it was like a you can go
before me if you want
oh you said just a short parcel yeah
just like among men harmony because
Chamber Choir it makes sense so ours
I'll do a few lines so signify are owed
to the the Brotherhood is all we need
through to win to fight way I'm getting
messed up now okay you go and now you
know it was like Hail Mary time I got to
do something and now wait and now let
hand grip into hand and I look I to I
breaks wait and breaks the we love
loving band of Beta Theta Pi Beta Theta
Pi my boys off Beta Theta Pi I'm so
nervous I'm sorry you waited for it yeah
I love singing I love my boys so yeah
that's that was that yeah
[Music]
he had a lot of eyes on him so that
means a lot of people were thinking
about him I think he dug his own grave
with that one thought I had it not gonna
lie I was pretty positive but yeah and
with the the multiple mold being thrown
in once those red lights hit I was so
shocked because I had no idea like what
just happened four moles wasn't even in
my realm of possibility honestly was
really only Abraham that I really
thought it was yeah I thought you were a
bald dude I thought you were able and I
thought you were involved so I was
trying to keep you guys in close when
you voted me out cuz you thought I was
in a frat
I thought you were in a friend I thought
I was like hundred percent you were in a
friend what people really don't see is
that people are joining an organization
for a real reason like for me personally
it was I wanted to meet new people feel
like nowadays it's more of like where
you fit in type thing it's not whether
you should be let in
we go I'm gonna take half of it yes sir
I'm gonna give you about half of it one
down right here yes all right one into
the box for all the people I sent home
and the rest firstly that was crazy Phil
good job on the track guys and the
multiple moles you had me did not see
that one coming
mostly not frat guys mostly not frat
guys but to all guys out there a big
thank you to manscape dot-com for
sponsoring this episode
this is the new perfect package
three-point okay this is actually the
razor this is the kit it's large there's
a lot of things in here
firstly let's talk about the razor the
lawnmower 3.0 pop it open here
ergonomic design with quality ceramic
blades and advanced skin safe technology
a super powerful quiet stroke motor very
very quite a premium lithium-ion battery
lasts up to 90 minutes a rapid charging
dock which is powered by USB cordless
and waterproof so you could use it in
the shower or the ocean yes a lazy river
it is compact it's adjustable and these
are the anti tug adjustable trim guards
which is important depending on what
you're shaving I guess and a built in
LED light that iluminates grooming areas
for closer more precise trimming or your
house when it's dark middle of the night
for a limited time subscribers get not
one but two free gifts the shed travel
bag which is a bag for traveling and the
patented high-performance anti chafing
landscape boxer briefs which are
underwear you put on your body and they
go under your pants you can get 20% off
plus free shipping from your perfect
package 3.0 purchase when you use promo
code
Jub 20 at manscaped comm thank you for
watching yeah